[Musique]
le biathlon un ancêtre lointain
l'épreuve de ski militaire
des soldats en tenue de combat qui
s'affrontent sur les pistes et au säntis
aujourd'hui vêtements carabine
techniques de ski la métamorphose est
totale
mais le défi reste identique
[Applaudissements]
dans une europe entre deux guerres des
patrouilles militaires s'élance avec
armes et bagages 30 km de ski 18 tirs
sur cible
une épreuve qui n'aura plus sa place
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
m
quand elle revenait aux jeux de 1960
elle prend officiellement le nom de
biathlon une épreuve individuelle est
ouverte au civil où le tir demeure
primordiale chaque balle ratée entraîne
des pénalités
à l'époque on ajoute deux minutes au
chronomètre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'athlète doit maîtriser deux positions
en tir debout
le défi c'est la stabilité l'athlète ne
misent donc pas sur ses muscles de sur
son ossature
il appuie le coude sur la hanche écarte
les jambes
son squelette alors format supports
rigides
[Musique]
si le canon 18 de plus d'un millimètre
le tirera pas seul
en position couchée l'athlète est stable
mais la cible est deux fois et demie
plus petit dans sa mire son
grossissement 1 se résume à un point le
vin joue alors un rôle de premier plan
le chantier comporte des fanions
qu'indique la force et la direction du
vent
une rangée à mi-parcours l'autre juste
devant les tireurs c'est elle la plus
déterminante car la même déviation en
début trajectoire a plus d'effet qu'en
fin de parcours
c'est parfois assez pour rater la cible
même les meilleurs rac1 tient sur 10
pour compenser les pénalités de tas de
biens tonia doit redoubler d'efforts en
skiant affronterait le biathlon profite
aussi des avancées en ski de fond non
seulement pour ce qui est de
l'équipement utilisé mais aussi des
différentes techniques pour se propulser
avec le patin les jambes ne fournissent
qu'un tiers de la poussée le reste
provient du haut du corps
l'esc et avec une carabine de 3,5 kg
force à s'adapter
c'est un poids supplémentaire qu'il faut
balancer de gauche à droite
des milliers de fois l'athlète réduit
l'amplitude de ces mouvements des gestes
plus courts et donc moins puissant pour
obtenir la même propulsion il doit
compenser en augmentant la cadence
[Musique]
que ce soit en solitaire ou en
patrouille ces skieurs qui se
transforment leurs tireurs d'élite offre
toute une démonstration de force
[Musique]